[Music]
hello
and welcome to the round 10
of the candidates tournament to the
breakdown studio live
with grand master ernesto narkieff and
woman grandmaster tina bellinger
you've made absolutely the right move by
joining us
yes today we will have a closer look to
the most beautiful games of round 10 of
candidates tournaments
we'll be also joined by a very special
guest international mastermind campaign
but first first let's look to the
standings because
all the games of today are finished and
we can already
check what is the standings uh
right now after this round so dina so
the leader
is um as yesterday
the same yanni bomnishi with six and a
half
points yes he won his game today and now
he
he is clear one point lead behind others
which is
pretty impressive yes this is very big
advantage already
very nice achievement we have three
players with the same number of points
five and a half
on the second position is fabiano karana
then there is maxine vashilagraf
and on the fourth standing place is
anish kiri even though
all of them once again have the same
number of points
yes and they also have a comfortable
advantage uh
i have a head of next players uh chinese
grandmaster wang hao
and russian grandmaster alexander
grishouk both of them had four and a
half points
and on the bottom of our standing we
have
dingle ren and kiril alexenka both with
four points
yes uh so we we can see that
the tournament divided on the different
group of players some of them are
leading
and still have a hopes to qualify to the
match against magnus carlsen and for the
others
they still have to the chances to beat
the leaders and to show the best but
it looks very difficult for example to
dean clear and to coach the leader
so uh let's uh go now to the games
which were played today today was very
exciting round
in the game one uh fabiana carrana
played against dean cleren
uh fabiano had a white pieces and as
didn't lyran is
uh currently outsider of the tournament
it is obvious that fabiano was hoped to
beat dean clitton
at the same time as we mentioned that
dean lyron in his best
chess he can beat anyone in the world
and today actually they had very
interesting fight which we will
analyze in deep later on so stay with us
in the second game or today was the game
french grandmaster
washer lagrav maxim against giri anish
this is supposed to be
the most interesting game from the
sportive point of view especially
as both players shared their feelings
after the previous round
so tina can you can you tell us what
what they said
uh do we have a tweets yeah let's take a
look at the tweets
of uh maxim vashiela graf
yes uh as you remember maxim started the
tournament uh
visa loss against fabian carano and
yesterday he had a very bad position
against including so after this game
he said that he set his feelings
i got into lots of trouble at some point
i was sure the position would just
collapse in two moves
in the end i managed to save this game
but it won't go into the collection of
my best games for sure
you know this is very special moment in
the game i mean before the players
resign
you always feel that the game is over
you first of all you resign in your
heart
and what i see in these words of maxim
is that he already
more or less resigned at some point of
this game so he sought already okay
few moves and i will have to resign my
position will collapse
and this is a certain point on on when
he already more or less stop fighting
but
he got lucky he survived the game and i
believe this will give him
uh extra motivation for this tournament
so he still have a very good chances to
fight for for the win
and i i believe this was a crucial
moment for his tournament also
yes totally agree with you and it's true
that uh any competitive chess player
should never resign
psychologically even if the game is
totally lost this might not have been
the case for maxine but
as you mentioned somehow he got lucky
and
yes let us let us hope to see many more
exciting games uh
from him yes and and the opposite he
plays
with giri anish who won yesterday's game
so it is obviously that anish
was motivated very high he was happy to
win the game and this is what he said in
the press
conference after the match
now let's have a look at the niche tweet
i had already the experience once i
played in the candidates and i kept the
chances until the end but
you have to at some point win some games
i found out
it's not enough that the tournament goes
well and
nobody's pulling ahead you also need
yourself to win games at some point
so it's good to win one and
uh we'll see what happens later yes i
think
uh anish refers to his tournament his
previous candidates tournament what he
played when he made all 14 draws in good
positions and everybody expecting that
next game he will win next game he will
win he still have a good chances and
finally the tournament just finished and
he still had
only 14 draws so this thing was very
important for him psychologically
i'm sure about that so this game was uh
important for both very much important
for both players i remember one
uh one very very famous meme in the
internet so going like
how would a hikaru checkmate in one
queen
queen g7 manchester would check mate
with queen h7
and anish guri would uh make a stalemate
with queen f7
okay okay so this was a interesting game
vashir made interesting novelty but giri
uh replied uh
very decently and the game uh was drawn
after all
the third game of today is uh uh the
game one hour against alexander grishouk
uh both players as we already saw in
standings
are behind the leaders and they played
today very sharp game
one house sacrificed the queen uh and
actually grishok had a very good chances
to win this game but
it was crazy and trouble both of players
didn't have time
and after uh after the blue
left after the time control the it was
the again the draw is
drawing position and the game number
four
of today is the only resultative game
for today
yes and actually our game of the day is
a game
uh yanni pondiche against kirill
alexianca
this is the game of the day very
interesting and exciting game and we
will
also analyze it in deep later on
so now it is time it is time to welcome
our guests uh today we have a very
special guest uh international master
malcolm paine ceo of chess in schools
hello welcome to hear us
yeah hey beautifully hi dean hello
malcolm it's a pleasure to have you here
with us thank you for coming
i see on the screen i've just been
announced as elia so i've now taken over
uh aegon so you guys are all working for
me now it seems
or maybe they're going to put my name up
instead we'll see they will for sure
yes we are so remarkable yes this is uh
this is our mistake
but now i think the viewers will see
your correct name
uh so you have very interesting uh
story in organizing a lot of chess
projects such as
events uh the first and i think the most
uh interesting will be for our view
viewers uh the story about
uh chess in school in uk
especially the project when you make
during pandemic uh
when you uh helped a lot of kids to play
chess to cut to connect uh
in the society around chess uh please
uh share uh with us uh your thoughts
uh how you got this idea how you managed
to make it work and what
the kids uh impressions about
this project sure so
i run 10 years ago i started a charity
to try and put chess back into british
schools because
it disappeared uh to put it simply
uh teachers in the 1980s uh
weren't very um weren't very happy with
the government that we had in the
in the uk so the government was a
conservative government and teachers
tend to be a little bit more
to the left of the political spectrum
and teachers
uh had lots of argument with the
government about
pay and conditions and all these sorts
of things and
in the end teachers just stopped doing
things voluntarily and
chess was one of those things that used
to be in school but it was usually
because a teacher did it voluntarily and
when the teacher stopped doing this
chess started to disappear
so by the time it got to 2010 we didn't
have very many schools with
with chess clubs in in the uk certainly
not in
in government schools in the in the
schools where people pay for uh
for education to the school privately
then of course they have lots of chess
and lots of other things
so i started to put chess back into
these schools and
what i did was i um i i essentially
copied the armenian
method and i decided that the best thing
to do was to put it in the classroom
because if you if you say what i always
said to a head teacher at the beginning
was
they'll say to me well we need uh we
need a chess club in the school what can
you do for me malcolm and i said well if
you have a chess club
and you go to the children it's you know
8 30 in the morning at the assembly and
say children there will be a chess club
tomorrow with half past three after
school
well 30 children will arrive but 27 of
them will be boys
three of them will be girls and two of
those girls of course will run away
because there are 27 boys
and so none of the girls will ever play
i said what you need to do
is you need to put it in the classroom
and then you'll get 15 boys and 15 girls
everyone will learn and this is a better
way of doing it
and uh to my surprise uh it it turned
into an
a great success uh to the extent that
we've taught 250 000 children since we
started the charity
of course when in in answer to your
question when the pandemic started
we couldn't go into the schools anymore
all the schools were closed
so i uh i contacted the guys who run
chesskid.com
uh this is a kind of a children's
version of chess.com
and i asked them to give me a million
subscriptions to
uh to the website a million gold
subscriptions of course i never imagined
i'd get a million children
but it's a great idea for pr so um to go
to the
newspapers and the television and say
hey i've got a million a million
subscriptions you know to this thing
everyone can play
and uh we got a lot of publicity and
actually in the end we signed up over 70
000 children so uh this was really great
i'm very very pleased with the with the
success of this project and
over half of them are still playing so
we actually have the biggest chess club
in the uk online
um so it's been transformational in some
ways
how do you develop this project i mean
you said that uh more than half of them
are still playing you can follow them
maybe organize some events uh
what what is happening right now how you
uh managed to build this associative
for these kids who is playing chess
right now
yeah so by putting them all in one chess
club it means you can communicate with
them all
and so we run tournaments every single
day we keep a league table of which
children are solving the most puzzles
with children are playing the most games
all these sorts of things you play
matches against other countries we had a
match against the united states
and we keep them interested in in that
way and we send a
chess lesson to every school every week
for the teachers to to distribute
and we also have our tutors looking at
the children's progress so we can see
exactly
how many videos they've done how many
questions they got right how many
puzzles they've solved
and that's how we keep the momentum uh
going forward
and in terms of getting kids involved
into chess
uh is that still a hard task in the 21st
century i mean with all this uh social
media tick tock
and uh the whole online gaming
how how difficult is that to get the
kids interested in chess
well what all the things you've said all
sound like problems
but actually you turn them into
advantages when you say to the teachers
or to the politicians
actually what we're doing is the reverse
of this we're
increasing children's attention span
we're giving them a traditional activity
that will increase concentration
and so while it may be not the simplest
thing to convince an individual child
actually that's not the best way to
market it the best way to market it is
to
to the schools to the people who control
the funds that go into education and so
what it actually does
is it gives us a very good story to tell
and actually when i say a story i mean
something that's actually real and
actually true
so while there are all these
distractions uh we find that
using uh these distr using these
distractions in our in our publicity
material helps get us more supporters
and of course then when children
actually play chess as i'm sure you know
uh of course they love it so they just
they just carry on so you just have to
get over the initial hurdle
and also when you do chess in school
when you do chess in a school classroom
the children don't think of it as a
lesson so of course it's a lesson
they're learning all kinds of things but
they think of it as like playtime
so they actually really look forward to
doing it uh
more than say mathematics or science or
or english or something like that so
there's no problem getting the kids
involved in that way
and in general it's it is not just kids
that you
actually help and get interested into
chess right
right yeah the the name of the charity
is chess in schools and communities
so we also do chess in public libraries
and we also do
a program in prisons i've got all sorts
of
interesting experiences i've had inside
british prisons
meeting all kinds of how can i say
interesting people
and we have uh we have chess club going
on in seven prisons we managed to enter
uh a team into the world internet
championship for prisons which is great
and uh i really enjoy the the time spent
in prisons if only because
the prisoners are incredibly grateful
they're so happy that people are doing
things for them
and uh well there are i would say
broadly speaking two kinds of prison in
the uk
um there's new modern prisons uh which
are very very nice and
and you know i would say are fit for a
human being to live in
but there are also some prisons built in
victorian times
uh to you know in not not even uh not
even in the 20th century but in the 19th
century
and these are awful places and
we've worked in some of those places and
the the chess is well first of all the
prison governors like it because
it gives the prisoners something to do
it gives them something to do that's
constructive
and uh it helps feed into the the
attempts of the prison education system
to make these people more employable
and also prisoners like it because
it's it kills the time so um
i could tell you a story i'll give you a
little sort of english
slang expression so i was doing a
simultaneous in one prison in
in in south london and uh
well it was slightly depressing because
i met one of the prisoners in the symbol
i'd met him in
another prison a few years ago so he'd
obviously uh
reoffended as they say or maybe been
transferred i don't know
he didn't come to play the symbol he
said to me
yeah he said well i played a symbol
against him in wandsworth and i was
playing a symbol against him in tens
mood you know a different two different
prisons
he goes mr payne he said mr payne is a
you speak
very very london accent you know very
landed actually mr payne he goes
i love this chess i said well why why do
you love this chest he goes
it's a bird killer a bird killer now
when he said bird killer doesn't mean
that he picks up the chess pieces throws
them at the birds in the sky and kills
them
bird is a slang expression in in prison
for being in prison
so what he's saying is you know it makes
the it makes the time
it makes the time go away uh so there
are all sorts of very very positive
things uh
about chess in prisons and and actually
during the pandemic we we
changed our approach so we couldn't go
into the prison but what we've been
doing
is sending puzzles and exercises and
books
into 40 prisons in the uk uh which is
which is very good and
now we've just got permission to get uh
chess.com in a couple of prisons
so prisoners will be able to actually
play chess uh obviously it's very
carefully controlled
of course you know we don't want a bank
robbery being organized on chess.com
that wouldn't be good
um but it's uh the security the security
measures have been checked and
uh i think this is going to really boost
the chess uh chess imprisons program
significantly
yeah this is also very unique i i
haven't heard about this one
before i uh stepped upon your website
to be honest i still think this is quite
unusual for chess i have a feeling that
this is still very new steps for chess
community to to find
what chess can bring to the world beside
entertainment beside educational part
and the you obviously can compare it as
a very experienced
organizer so what uh
what will be your thoughts about the
future of chess i mean uh
in generally is it should be the
strategical point of developing the
chess uh to try to find some new
way to bring uh good things to the
society uh this is uh maybe should be
one of the main
thing what the chess organizers should
do now what
how do you think it absolutely is and
the
the spanish chess journalist uh garcia
is a great expert and a great pioneer in
developing the
the the social benefits of chess so uh
one of the things that that he talks
about is
the fact that chess is so universal that
anyone can play it you know it doesn't
matter about your language or your
gender or if you have a disability or
whether you're a rich person or a poor
person chess can be for you
and one one of the things i think we
should do and a lot of people do in a
lot of countries is try and get more
chess
played in public spaces try and get
played more in in in libraries like we
do it like we do in the uk
and i'm really a great fan of uh these
public
uh chess parks you know like in
washington square park in new york or
like uh like you see in in russia
certainly you see in hungary and
and amsterdam and other places where
chess is just it's just part of the
cultural fabric of a country
and i think that's really one of the
most important things that fide
could do to do to develop chess over the
next century
and now that we have already mentioned
the the total spread
worldwide of chess nowadays uh
especially this last year i may ask you
why chess isn't still recognized as a
sport in the united kingdom
yeah so it's a it's a complete disaster
for us
and it's something we've been fighting
very very hard and we keep just having
incredibly bad luck when i say we it's
it's kind of me actually but but um we
we've we've had
incredibly bad luck for example uh gary
kasparov came over
to the uk uh a long time ago spoke in
the parliament i think this would be
late 90s yeah late 90s when tony blair
was elected in 1997 yep and
the sports minister was a great fan of
chess
and gary went to talk to him and we made
a lot of progress
and i went to see the minister in charge
which was great i had no problem getting
uh
getting a time to talk to him he
promised to put some legislation
into parliament uh but then some other
priorities came
came about and and it ran out of time
and then and
we we had another disaster when the
minister was a really nice guy called
tony banks
but he became uh seduced by the idea he
decided it would be a great idea to try
and get england to stage the world cup
and he invested a load of time in that
of course
and as you'll know from some of these uh
the house of fifa for example is a
fantastic book to read
a lot of the voting was uh was was
corrupt and
that's why a lot of those guys are being
arrested by the fbi and
in england england didn't get the world
cup and then paul tony banks died
um and then the following sports
minister wasn't a great fan and the
following one after that
and then finally uh about three years
ago i started to make more progress
but of course brexit took over every
politician's time
right and then once brexit was done i
thought okay we have a we have a chance
i made the approaches again but of
course then we had covid
so it's just always have everything
extremely difficult
to um to get the recognition but the
story of why it's not
a um not a sport is actually a very
interesting story
so um if you can imagine in 1936
uh various people i mean mainly
churchill but not just churchill
realized that this guy adolf hitler you
know maybe he's not such a nice guy
and um i mean of course a lot of british
people
didn't appreciate this uh because so
many people
had had an awful experience of course in
the first world war so they were
very very very worried about any other
kind of conflict or war
but certainly the the civil servants the
the people running the government in in
britain some of them were certainly
aware of it
of the of the potential for war so they
thought well what should we do
and i thought well one of the things to
do would be to get the men
much more physically fit because you're
going to need them to be physically fit
if they go to the army
so they decided that it would be very
very good to pass an act of parliament
uh defining what a sport was so that
they could then say right we want
everyone to
start playing these sports they'll get
fitter they'll be better soldiers
and unfortunately in that act of
parliament in 1937
chess was not included and
the irony of that is of course that the
most
important contribution to the war
generally was made by the chess players
in
the code breaking at bletchley park when
they solved the enigma code
right and so it's it's just ironic
that chess had chess and chess players
made an incredible contribution to
to the war effort but the um
the government legislation and ideas to
assist the war effort
excluded chess so i'm afraid what is it
uh 84 years we haven't been recognized
but look i'm still trying
um and i i'll be starting again soon as
as soon as the pandemic is over i'll be
i'll be knocking on doors again
that sounds pretty unfair to be honest
oh completely yeah but it's it's just a
real
it's just a reality although i would say
that we are making some progress
in that the government is now coming to
us so i'm also involved in the english
chess federation
and uh i've recently uh well i say
recently
it actually popped into my inbox an hour
ago if you can imagine
um i got a i got an email from
um from the uh ministry of uh the home
ministry the ministry that deals with
immigration
asking if the english chess federation
could be the official body to confirm
that if somebody wants to immigrate to
the united uh to come into the united
kingdom to be a professional chess
person
oh really that we will confirm that
they're the right person so we will be
like
uh the authorizing body so it's
fascinating to me
that the government is approaching us
and saying well you're the legal body
but at the same time they're not
recognizing us as a sport
but this will just give you more
ammunition you know i'll keep trying
that is actually a very very
interesting topic because uh in many
many different countries
uh if a player let's say lives for for
some years in another country and wants
to change the federation he cannot
because he doesn't have the
the passport the nationality but in in
your case it sounds like you are given
the right to to decide and to influence
the whole process
well not yet i mean we have to com we've
just been asked if we will do it
for sure but it's interesting i mean
essentially there are rules about coming
to this country to work you know
particularly now we're not in the
european union and i think
what the government government's
position always is
is if you've got a profession or a skill
which we don't have in the uk
or we don't have enough of in the uk
then they'll let you in and i think what
they want us to do
is to verify and to confirm that
someone's saying they are a
you know a professional chess player
they really are a chess player
that's really all he wants to do okay so
if we need to we will step back we'll
knock on your door
we don't know if you want to come and
live here you you know where to come
yes okay then 2020 of course was very
difficult a year for
for all uh uh
how can you describe uh the results uh
uh for your project uh
for for for your development in chairs
uh what
pandemic brought or what it took
so what what is in generally uh results
of of all
the chess projects in uk right now
sure i mean what of course the pandemic
is a catastrophe
for the world and and for everyone and
and now we've just got
i think recently the number of people
killed was three million
but for chess actually it's it's been
remarkably positive
um just because i mean with obviously
with the obvious exception of some of
the chess players we know who've died
uh because who got the disease but aside
from
from that terrible thing uh the lockdown
just boosted chess enormously i mean the
figures have gone
crazy and then the queen's gambit
just i mean chess is now
so popular in the uk it's it's mentioned
in the newspapers it's it's appearing in
advertisements
um i also have a chess shop by the way
and the number of people buying chess
sets has increased
greatly so the pandemic itself i think
has boosted chess
and now once the pandemic ends it's
really i think the responsibility of us
chess players to uh
to take advantage to take advantage of
all these new players or
in a lot of cases people who were lapsed
players you know they played when they
were at school and now they've
seen the queen's gambit and thought oh
let's get into chess again
it is a huge opportunity i mean it's a
long time since we had huge feature
articles
in the new york times or in vanity fair
or
vogue magazine you know this is i think
this is an unprecedented opportunity
but for all chess projects really
okay obviously would love to know
what you think about the candidates
tournament as well do you stay neutral
or do you have a fan here
yeah i stay strictly neutral
mainly because as the organizer of the
london chess classic
i mean i used to be involved in the
grand chester as well but not anymore
but as the organizer of london chess
classic you know i try and stay
completely neutral and impartial
although i noticed that there was um
there was there was a
a little bit of the london chess classic
in the games today um
which uh uh i mean you know uh uh
paul carroll played absolutely terribly
today of course but
if he'd have played the way that
kayaking played against mickey adams in
the london chess classic in 2017 uh
although it's still a bit better for
white
it doesn't it's not losing immediately
so
uh yeah i was uh i i think though that
there are some statistics if you look at
the last three candidates the person
winning in round 10 is usually the
winner
although i noticed that that ian still
has to play
uh fabian maxime so i suppose that's
that's really those are the two key
games aren't they
probably the last question uh for today
um in 2018
you said that you would be potentially
interested
in running for the president of
defeating
in 2022 as far as i remember
do you still plan to run and uh if
yes i've got absolutely no plans to do
that
um i have to say though that that
getting involved in that election was a
very interesting
and completely unique experience for me
and
although i didn't realize it at the time
i think i enjoyed it quite a lot
uh but uh i think i've i've had uh i've
had my
uh i've had my experience yeah and uh
i'd be
i'd be unlikely to uh unlikely to do it
again
but what is it they say never say never
right yeah
maybe you can uh share with that the
main idea what should be done in the
chess world for example
uh if you would be a world feeder
president right now
the the main thing what what would you
done imagine imagine yeah
well you know actually it's funny you
say imagine you know i went to the same
school as john lennon yeah
you know wow how could you know that
yeah
so i'm very oh i'm very good at imagine
i'm very good at imagining
um yeah i mean i i think that
that what we would seek to do is is is
is try and engage um more governments
more sports bodies
but and but also more cultural
organizations in in
in spreading awareness of of what chess
can do for society generally
um and probably i mean i have to say
that i think that
uh the um the the current people in
charge of fide
have done an extremely good job in many
ways uh in the
i'd say things are are better organized
than they were
but it's almost like um what is it mount
saitung used to say you say waiting for
the great leap forward that's it
i still think that in terms of
commercial sponsorship
which i think is something we should be
able to achieve now
for chess with the the increased amount
of popularity i think that's really
where
where where we need to advance more it's
a shame that despite
the fact that chess is front and center
in the media
uh that we still don't have a a huge
you know a big a big corporate sponsor
for really for for anything that we do
we are very very uh
i mean we have a few small sponsors and
a few sponsors of individual tournaments
and individual teams and countries
but an overreaching global sponsor for
chess
like you have in uh in other sports that
i think is
uh is really the the big objective
malcolm paine international master thank
you so much for being with us
it was a privilege to have you here
thank you it was so interesting have a
good evening
bye yeah it's uh very interesting you
know
frankly i didn't play many tournaments
in uk somehow
uh despite of having visited uh i think
all countries all over the europe
and still the first ever uh
international chess tournament was
organized in london do you know that uh
yeah that is actually um pretty special
i i wanted once to uh
to participate in london classic um
didn't manage to but
i i did play twice in the uk
uh in gibraltar in 2019 and 2020
actually deposit 2020 was my last over
the board tournament before the
the spread of the covet virus
yes that is uh that is pretty special
for us you know
um pretty pretty different uh it's not
just like open tournaments uh
in europe which are we are you and me i
guess we're the most used to
and also chasing schools i believe it's
uh pretty
unique i i was i was truly impressed by
by the numbers to get one million kids
uh
free membership at chess.com making one
million kids uh
play chess that is uh that is impressive
yeah actually this is uh
we're in uh maybe the most popular
project in chess right now
uh there is uh i should say many
countries already
uh understand that this is very
interesting project and this is what
should be done
uh of course uh uh the biggest maybe uh
countries
who make this this is russia obviously
uh china also they also have a chairs in
schools
so uh i'm very curious to see what will
be after 10 or 20 years
when we will have a generation of people
who who's
already learned how to play chess from
the childhood uh
to calculate their uh things what they
are doing in life
i think it will be very interesting the
new generation brought up by malcolm
yes so am i let us now switch to the
game the game
of the day yes so let's come to the
chess part
today we have uh one extremely
important game it is a game
which janji pomnishi played against
kirill alexinka
this game is so important from the
sporty point of view
because after this game jan is a
sole leader with one point ahead of
others
and the way he played this game uh
remind me one one thing but before
i will tell it uh how do you think there
it is
there is uh something uh in cheers what
we can compare with box can we can
purchase this box yeah for sure
we do not need to go far away to search
for an example there is chess boxing as
a different uh variant of chess uh
i'm pretty sure you can compare this too
yes the game
reminds me the famous uh float like a
butterfly sting like a bee
his hands can't hit what his eyes can't
see
this is what was actually uh doing nepal
during this game
he played very quickly he didn't spend
much time over the board
well this one doesn't actually surprise
me it is his style
yes but not always uh and also
uh he played a very very good game
from the outside it looks like he had an
easy day like a walk in the park
but of course if you go deep in this
game you understand that he
made a very very good job first of all i
should admire his
team his preparation let's let's start
let's look to the chessboard yeah on the
first day of our um
coverage uh sergey kraken uh said that
uh yanniborn she did have a very nice a
very good team
team yes vladimir podkin is he's a
his coach team leader i can say i
believe that he's not the one
yeah sergey has enough experience to say
that yes okay so
uh jan chose uh english opening
uh this is not a big surprise because
mainly he plays or e4 or c4
and actually g3 the the second move he
also played already uh
in in the past time so i believe kirill
should expect
this move order e6 bishop g2 g5
when i was telling that his team met
amazing job
i meant that he got the position where
black don't have a clear way a clear
plan how to play you have a lot of
moves but they looks more or less
similar
and in this situation if you're not uh
very much familiar with the position
it's very easy to make mistake
yeah definitely you can uh also
confuse the openings and mix it for with
uh queen's gambit uh
the slav defense the queen's gambit
refuse decline the
the slav defense uh the terrorist could
even
yes many openings can happen from this
position
yeah go on yes so um
kirill decided to to try to to clarify
the the position he he played the take
c4
this is still theory will not stop for
long here queen a4
knight bd7 queen c4 a6 this is first uh
uh instructive moment in the position
black is uh ready to play b5 and bishop
b7
and actually all this line is about this
bishop on c8 if black will be able to
develop this bishop
uh usually they can equalize the
position
so from this moment the dance is
starting
queen c2 so jan avoiding b5
if black will play b5 right now then
after knight d4 we can see that
the rook on a8 is attacked and
you don't have uh any places for it
because 96 is coming
yeah this is dangerous so b5 is not
possible
uh kirill plays c5 which is very natural
it looks almost like my favorite queen's
gambit accepted but with the bishop on
g2 and that makes the
the whole difference yes and the pawn on
d2
yes and this one also and uh well it's
just actually this
uh yeah these two which are which are
different but
it's way more they more advantage to
white you mean setup for black is
similar yes
yes is similar yes to get yes correct
uh and now is uh after necessary the
first moment uh uh
in which black uh have to decide how to
play
this is this is looks like a symbol
position because all ideas
is unfold so you can understand them but
the move order is extremely important it
is obviously that you will already
forget
how to play yes so he played
bishop e7 looks a very natural move but
actually this is
uh this is inaccuracy
we should perhaps mention that uh these
players have tons of preparation
every every day for every round and uh
they spend two to three hours to repass
everything but they still manage to
forget simply because there are millions
of different lines
by the way i'm not sure if that's the
best for approach i do know that fabiano
carana
is well known to spend up to three hours
before the actual game
but most of the coaches uh can
give the advice to avoid that one not to
get uh to get too much tired and
not to spend more than one hour what is
what is your
um preference ernesto you are very
experienced grandmaster european
champion
yeah it depends on on the moon on
situation this is true that
the player should keep the energy and
the mood before the game
and this the danger when you spend three
or more hours in preparation it's not
only about energy this is also about
mood because
there is no guarantee that after three
hours you will feel confident enough
maybe you will discover much more
problems and you will go to the game
thinking that you don't have nothing
it's like the more you ask
the more you want to you should be ready
to to get the answers which maybe you
will not like
uh my experience is uh sometime i just
have a
very strong motivation to find a novelty
i like this process very much i always
involved in the process not only my
coaches
is doing this work uh generally i am
decide what i'm going to play build the
general player plan of the game
i like this very much and uh still i
think
all together i spent uh for maybe about
four hours but i tried to split it
yes like two hours uh before going to
bed in the evening and then two hours in
the morning
yeah like that and and also i spent some
time uh during for example walking
during resting i should say that one of
the biggest
uh challenge for all these participants
is that during this tournament they
uh actually have no rest because our
brains is always working
yeah even even if they have two days of
uh of
the rest which is by the way the first
uh free day will be tomorrow
that means no broadcast from our part
but do not worry we'll be back
to you on friday but yes uh there will
be also a
free day on on sunday but you see that
that that doesn't actually change their
their mind they they are
in this constant process of thinking of
uh
of caring about what they they they they
are planning to
to to do on the board and uh yes do they
actually manage to to relax or not at
all
uh i believe that the players enjoy what
they are doing and
i i think they're not tired because of
that because when you get what you want
this is a very very much
enjoyable you you have very good mood
motivation energy and this is how it
goes and of course when you have bad
tournament it's all
goes opposite okay so let's come back to
this game
uh in this position uh kirill played
bishop e7 but actually correct move
order would be queen c7 first
with idea b6 and then bishop b7 so once
again he should think first about this
bishop on c8 this
was crucial uh
oops do not spoil everything yes okay
uh so after bishop
bishop seven they castled first and then
white already played d4 so what is the
point uh the most natural reaction would
be c takes d4
what will happen after uh attacked
actually he took right now
and this is a um this is uh another
inaccuracy after after which you already
get in the uh
really unpleasant position and starting
from that moment jan didn't give him
any any second chance yes i just want to
show
how difficult it was to defend i mean
the best and the only way to
to get equal position was move b5 this
is very risky because
now white have knight e5 or with the
idea
um that the bishop will attack the rook
on e8
yeah this is totally unnatural uh
opening the bishop like that
and what black should do here is to take
not take c5
if uh white will take on eight then c
takes d4 and black have very strong
sense one
okay yeah the bishop takes the work
okay i will show it see takes d4 and
this is very good compensation for the
black because i have very strong
sensor fair enough but i believe that
what
kirill was worried about is uh i
definitely heard
he considered this idea that after
knight takes e5 white can take the takes
e4
knight d5 and rook d1 and it looks like
it's over because e4 is coming d5 is
hanging
yeah and there's an x-ray to the queen
yes
so it looks like game over
yeah okay let me show it okay
uh they're actually like there was in
the x-ray here and the pin of the night
yeah let's
looks yes normally you just stop here
your calculations because
on their level yes you understand
already that
it's not going to happen good for you
but suddenly after bishop
7 white uh can't win any scene so
uh and uh it's enough to defend so
why don't have modern equality after e4
there is not before
oh nice this is um the
the counter attack yes and both queens
are attacked and there is uh
there is no no chance for a white to win
anything because if uh
white takes the queen then knight takes
c2 yes okay let me show it uh that's
true
not takes the eight not uh rook texas
yes yeah and there is and by the way uh
maybe here black is better yeah
okay yeah nice let's go back so uh to
keep equality
uh kirill should find this line uh this
is of course uh
was difficult and he didn't manage to do
it he simply took
knight takes d4 but this is actually uh
shows why it was very important to
develop this bishop because now
uh after white bishop attack b7 black
just cannot do that
and because of that they cannot finish
the development
i should say that what i see in this
start this reminds me my game against
alexander krishuk from 2014
i started to play queen's government at
that moment and
uh it was a challenging game for me and
it was a similar story i didn't develop
the bishop from c8 and
quickly get very very bad position and
uh afterwards krishuk explained me that
in catalan this is a most important idea
if you can develop this bishop you get
good position if you don't you
you bet and what i see here is a lack of
experience
we talked that kiril is young and
energetical but
this is how experience uh important
yeah okay so this is already this
position already seriously better for
jan
but he didn't win a pawn or a piece so
it required a lot of
um yeah there's no material advantage it
is uh
it is simply better by by the way the
pieces are placed that there is a
there is the activity there is the the
advantage of the development but
right it's still a matter of uh of a
technique of how you
actually convert and as we know the the
most uh
the toughest thing in chess is to win a
winning position
yes and uh we should say that jan didn't
give a real chances
for kiriel he played quickly as we
already mentioned he was moving away
come back to the plane hold just made a
move and go back
now this is his style yeah yes
why uh white's position is better
because it is much more easy for white
to develop the pieces rook goes to d1
bishop goes to e3 who goes to c1 and
if black can't develop the bishop from
c8 the rook on it is also bad you cannot
develop the rook and
it like the problem come one after
another you just cannot
uh avoid this yeah it is actually like
at first glance you you do see that both
bishops are not developed and both rooks
are not developed but actually
when you start to to analyze to look
deeper you
you do understand that uh y will develop
in like
this yes that's it okay so rook d8
bishop is three knight b6 rkc
one now it's already very obvious that
white have advantage in activity
all pieces developed rook on air bishop
on c8 is
bad and usually when we have a such
activity advantage we should already uh
search for some tactics and actually
this is what is happening here
black already don't have any moves which
is not losing something it's already
very hard to find the move which is not
losing any sin uh kirill tried the
active idea e5 so once again he's trying
to develop this bishop
somewhere but it is too late
after knight f5 bishop takes f5 contains
the advantage increased very much uh
so there's actually the king the black
king that is
now about to to get himself in trouble
with this queen on f5 and there will be
the bishop that will come later on on
e4 attacking the h7 and once again this
rook on
c8 the position looks um
[Music]
looks over but they were still
yeah it's uh there is uh
uh very hard to play of course but uh
the game still continue
and this is was uh more or less uh the
last moment uh
uh the critical moment yes for black
here
i believe kirill uh simply uh forgot
uh about so he took on divan developed
the rook and it looks like like he
almost
uh solved his problem he developed the
rook developed the bishop so it looks
like one two one more
one more move and it will be fine but
here comes
the decisive blow bishop takes f6
and then now we see that bishop takes f6
bishop b4
this is exactly what you mentioned and
suddenly a
attack on the king is starting yeah and
not much of a choice to to defend it and
uh as uh while we were preparing for
for the show we mentioned a very fine
funny
thing over here instead of
bishop takes f6 the computer was
actually
suggesting g6 in order to
just attack the queen to find the h7 and
simply give away this piece which looks
totally ridiculous for
for for player but um yeah so
the position is that bad that's computer
even considered just to play without a
piece as a possibility
alternative so after bishop f6 bishop
before it also was a
very big time trouble to funky real so
we just quickly go to the end of the
game because
nothing nothing was really happening he
he uh he defended hard but
it didn't help white just started to
take
everything down first then he sacrificed
the exchange
and at the end uh at the end we can see
that
uh black will lose the second pound
in any case and the game is over yeah
even if they're
this is an end game where perhaps we
should mention the end game of the
opposite called bishops and
many many players know that there are a
lot
there is a high chance of getting a draw
with the
with the opposite code bishops but it's
it's more in situations when you have
one pawn advantage but here two pawns uh
would be enough yeah since the f7 point
will
will fall apart pretty impressive um
pretty impressive game from jan and as
you said very important for for the
for the standings because the yanipo
machine right now is leading the
tournament with
one point ahead of all the other
participants uh
yes uh i should mention that i always
have a mixed
feeling after such a games first we can
say that uh kirill alexander made
a quite famous mistake i mean he could
he forget the theory made
inaccuracies and just simply get a bad
position so it looks like
uh uh yeah an easy game for young
easy game and it looks like jan didn't
made
a lot of things to win this game but it
is definitely not so
first it was a very clever choice of
opening
uh it's not as as we already saw kiril
had two games before and
other players couldn't uh find a
position in which he was
so uncomfortable as he was today and
uh the second thing uh how uh jan uh uh
lead this this game to the win so yes
the
fir first thing is to to get the
advantage from the opening
which was a home preparation so okay we
could potentially say that it wasn't
such
a young's um achievement
yes but uh at the same time he did show
a
perfect converting technique so
yes and also as you mentioned that when
the game finished he had more than one
hour on his clock
so kirill was already in time trouble
but young still was
had plenty of time to finish the game so
pretty uh
very much impressive and i should uh
mention that we didn't
actually talk uh much about yan in the
first games it looks like he was
hiring in the shadow of other players
but
uh in the round three definitely he
remind us who is the leader of the
tournament
so it's a perfect perfect game for our
show
yes so
let us go to the next game of this round
the second game
the most interesting game of today is a
game between fabiana caruana
and dinkliran but before we move to the
chess part of this game
we should mention that after the
tournament start
many players was telling their opinion
about
who is best who is best opponent for the
magnus carlsen
if you remember dina sergey karakin said
that his
favorite is fabiana caruana that he
plays very nice
and also a world champion himself magnus
carlsen
uh shared his thought about this so uh
he he said uh what
what he actually tweeted that uh
february would definitely be one of the
um one of the
yeah we have it on the screen let us
have a look i've said before that i
think fabiano is the strongest player so
in
terms of what match would be most
difficult
certainly him yes and today he even
added
that office any other players i will be
a clear favorite yeah magnus also
um mentioned that the
preparation of fabiano is extremely good
his calculation is definitely one of his
strongest
suits as well as just pure concentration
he often looks at moves what
magnus carlsen might reject
i think he was a wider search that
i do in a lot of positions
i think he has a wider search than i do
in a lot of positions
that is one that surprised me
to be crystal clear with you
magnus carson is known to to
to have to be having the the biggest the
the most uh professional and
profound team of um of seconds but he
still um
still mentions that faviano would
actually overcome him to
overcome in this my guess would be that
this is the second part of this
uh thought is uh about uh calculation of
fabiana
because it is known that uh kirwana uh
more
plays with calculation when the magnus
is more evaluation player
and frankly speaking when i was looking
the game caruana against the
clearance i felt that the boss players
is extremely good in calculations i had
my personal
experience with playing ding clearance i
played with him uh
six games i played with him and actually
it was interesting
i played these games during two years
period
i started with beating him in a very
interesting game and after that with
every new game i felt that
how he is growing extremely and it was
quite unpleasant
feeling for me as a player because i
felt like a guy is just better and
better you know with every game and
it felt very unpleasant for me yeah i
can imagine
yes and also what i felt about him is
that uh he is like
a machine uh he is a very nice person
to talk about chess and everything but
also he's very calm
he's doing his job extremely
professionally
and you can even feel it when you play
against him that he's calculating
everything you know
you he i i had this feeling that if the
in the position will be some concrete
line which
can be calculated he will find it
definitely and uh
coming back to our game uh i i want to
announce it as a game of
terminators so two two guys who
calculate uh
chess variations extremely good maybe
one of the best
calculators in the world yes okay after
chase calculators here let's say okay
operated after stock fish
yes okay so let's count to this uh
karana choose to play e4 once again as
he did against maxime
uh dean clearing is famous to especially
in the last time that he sticks
to same line same lines he believes in
his preparation
uh and the line what they played this is
a so-called
right lopez defense reload this game
uh also known to be the spanish opening
in our
version speaking circles yes correct is
panka and we spell it
uh this is uh all this position already
were played by
dinkliran uh and it was very interesting
what carolina prepared because as we
already
have seen in the first game he don't
come to the board without a surprise for
his opponent
this is uh quite sharp this is
considered always considered the
sideline
but it is very sharp uh and i can
imagine that it wasn't
especially unpleasant for the dean
clearing to to start to have this
position over the over the board today
was this uh so far uh the preparation
until now
yes even more in this position dean
clinton had already three games
he played with black so
so he does believe in his lines and yeah
he's pretty
is is a man of principle yes uh uh
so what his position is about uh we can
see that
uh white get a very strong sensor right
uh compared especially yeah to the d6
and e6 which are pretty weak well here
green color would be more positive than
the red one but
you get the points yes and also in chess
we say that the pounds are
uh are weak the pawn islands island yeah
yes it's true so black here has three uh
isles of pawns yeah the compared to
white
who has only only two
we can see that black pawns do not
connect between each other a6
do not connect with this response and
these two pawns also not connected that
means that
the bounds in the center e6 d6 and c7
will need more defense in the future
so this is a potential danger of black
position not only
the space advantage as a compensation
black got very active rook very
extremely
active rook right now i'm putting
everything which is good in green color
and everything which is bad
uh okay maybe we also had i should have
a blue one
to paint the picture for practice until
friday yeah okay let's imagine this is
fire
this is green hills we need lakes
we'll improve that for for friday for
the round 11.
so yes you mentioned the rook on b5
which is good but what else what else
could bring black uh
some compensation here oh the a5
so this is actually red i guess yes this
is already a victim
of a white strategy they sacrifice uh
this pawn
uh to get all and other factors of the
position this is pretty funny because
the a5 phone is advanced uh pretty far
away and
normally we do consider this as an
achievement as a space advantage
but here it happens to be a weakness so
it is quite
it is black to move so if they want they
can take this pawn right now
the point of white is not only the
center and the weak pawn in the center
is
also that a6 pound uh also weak uh
potentially
uh the main lines was what was played
before it moves
not takes a5 or knight before but i want
to mention that knight before is
considered the main line in the first
line of the engine
here white have very nice blow white
played d5 this is a key idea of this
line
can you guess what is the point if uh e
black will take
e takes d5 what is idea i can put it on
the board it takes d5
uh okay it is definitely not capturing
back uh this one i can understand
even from your uh from the way you speak
so i have queen b3 pinning the pawn
okay what else uh trying to attack
something
what else e5 e5 is the idea
oh yes there is knight d4 yes this is
right yes unexpectedly if you can see
that it looks like
there is no danger for black there is no
pieces but no white pieces
close to the black's position but after
knight knight d4
we can see there is two threats uh rook
p5 is under attack and also there is a
second idea 96 with a
yes this is a double attack actually you
attack the rook right now and you attack
the
the the double attack you attack the the
fork this is what i wanted to say
and uh do you think it was a blunder
from
from tinder it didn't happen in the game
i just showed you the main idea of this
line
so if black plays knight before for
example then d5 is
an idea after d5 black should not play
it takes d5 the main line goes with
knight g4 with the main
uh main idea after h3 for example just
take on f2
king takes and knight d3 this is one of
the main tactical idea for black to play
this position
but it didn't happen in the game but he
was acting he was definitely analyzing
this one
as an option so do you think it was a
blunder miss uh
mis-evaluating this chance uh i i uh
no it didn't happen then night before
this possible move so dink played it
before uh the same idea goes if black
plays knight takes a five it's again the
five
strong idea okay so uh i believe that
this was a prep of fabiana caruana he of
course
analyzed indeed what happens after night
before 95 and prepared something but
mr dink lyran came with uh some
vicious surprise with him in his hands
he played queen c8
uh first when i saw this move i couldn't
understand what is the point actually
he defends the e6 yes
square the one which just saw right
yes and now uh white don't have d5 at at
any moment
and so black uh will take the pawn on e5
or playing play night night before
in the next move white can't do anything
about that
so this is very strong novelty by dean
clearing
after which the position is uh very
unclear and very interesting
uh bishop striker on a plate he played
it quite quickly but i am
not sure was this his preparation
already or not because
he spent some time to sink uh now dink
took the pound queen c2 so it is a pound
sacrifice once again
fabiano sacrificing the material uh as a
compensation he still get this
very active pounds and potentially a six
pound is weak c7 pound is weak so it's
all the same story
uh but he didn't have now this d5 idea
sounds like a title of very famous t
film
yes okay so uh the game continues c5 uh
dink tried to change his weakness
immediately
e5 the the e d takes e5 so
very unusual position it's hard to
understand what is going on white have
very strong power on c5 at the same time
this uh e5 e6 they're weak pounds
they're horrible they're doubled and
they are
they there they are on the open file
they seem to be pretty weak and they see
five pawn uh seems to be a strong pass
bone but
you sound like there is a but yeah c4
maybe to play knight e4
and black should be ready to meet all
these sit-ups and let's say at the same
time
for white is also important to to play
it very quickly if you lose some some
moves so black will just have clear
extra pawn
so knight e4 it is a quite logical idea
to improve the rook from a1
i'm so much surprised that uh computer
relates this position as better for
black
yeah i also think that it's more
comfortable to play it with bite
this one is a pretty
yes pretty ugly putting the bishop like
this in front of two pawns oh my god i
i would never do such a move but uh i
guess this is why they are
they are in yeah and work this is why
they are the candidates
maybe this can be your improvement to
find out why this move is good and
make it yes
i frankly also don't like this move
because this
pure defense you you you have to defend
e5 and there is no other way to play
this position so this is what is
happening here
h4 so we see what the quran is trying to
do he
he want to say that his c5 pound split
black's position
on the sides the rook is uh not uh
taking part in the case cuts the board
into into
yes several parts and he wants to start
on attack on the king side
uh when the rook will be on b5 knight
will be on c6 so
the h4 is about that you want to attack
the black screen king
so after h6 stop in knight g5
uh here uh rook
the next moment is very interesting so
d5
yes how would you start attack for white
well just
bring us some ideas okay uh one thing
that comes immediately into my mind is
to
improve your knight to put it somewhere
to e4 like i would say
knight to knight to d2 and then knight
to e4 but we cannot do that because
there is knight d4 we need to control
this square
yes unfortunately it looks like we also
played also we cannot remove the bishop
because you have to play with xe5 now
yeah that is true okay but once again uh
speaking about this knight
it would be really great to move it away
because in that case the rook would be
able to to enter to g3 once again not
possible yet
so we could we could potentially start
with queen e4 then queen g4 or
immediately queen g6
so this one i like more queen g6 looks
like
yeah yeah and then okay queen g6 rook e4
and then rook g4 this would be my
my final choice this is very nice i like
dinner and there is 97
yes the move karana played the is
a bit unexpectable he plays g4
oh so he don't uh waste his time for
maneuvers he wants to play g5 and just
crush the king immediately
uh well before the players make such
moves they i think
they like to divide the board not only
this pawn divide the
the board also the e65 is also dividing
the boards
yeah so it's like this is a very very
particular position on the board uh
indeed we we could you know like cut the
board into several slices
and then uh like divide them completely
okay you stay here
you take this part and you consider the
other the other side
um still the computer gives advantage to
black why why uh is this happening
uh yes uh okay this computer is not
really strong
i should say the position is not better
for black uh so
ding clear and don't uh seriously had a
chances in this game
what i wanted to mention that the king
now is quite alone the only
peaceful who can defend the king now is
the bishop one of six so this is quite
dangerous for black black should be
ready to to do something
about the threat of g5 uh so uh the next
move uh queen eight is quite uh
understandable uh i think uh lyran led
another piece
to to defend the king king ju2 first
so very nice also bringing the rook yes
to g1 and to h1 participating into the
attack this one is
clear my favorite yes and here dean
claren decided not to wait
uh when other army will come
to the castle and to decide it to stop
it
first h5 g5 bishop e7
this is for this example simplification
after knight takes e5 all the pieces
just
just changed and this is already uh
more or less equal situation i also want
uh to mention that
instead of queen g6 for the moment uh
queen f4
looks more logical for me because if
white will be able to keep
this knight for example to play knight
f3s and take on e6
the the g5 pun can be very dangerous for
black
but uh black pieces now is very active
yes this rook's like usually you keep
the roofs on the on the eighth
or seventh franc but here they are in
front of the knight yeah this is pretty
unusual
because uh yeah once again you normally
keep the
the strategy to put your first your
minor pieces and then your
your major pieces but here they do look
uh
super strong yes and the most simple way
for black to play here is to go queen
five i like this
queen eight i like this move very much
because
uh queen is looking to the white king
right now and white uh forced to change
everything after knight c6 queen takes
queen takes
then rook takes c6 and this is just uh
once again this is just jewish position
yeah after
queen's uh get exchanged there is
nothing much for for black here anymore
unfortunately for
fabby's fans yes uh so in the game he
played queen g6 immediately this is uh
also also drawish line uh they just
changed all the pieces and
changed the rooks and it was just
perpetual check because
white cannot go forward king e3 because
of k rookie 2 or
f5 or knight f5 so it's just just fine
for black
i i should say that this is extremely
high quality game
very interesting opening strategy
obviously uh fabiano choose a very sharp
line to play
and dean lyron was prepared he came up
with a novelty
first and then they got absolutely
unbalanced strategically position
uh dean cleary had an extra pound but
the pants was weak
one pieces was on the king side another
on the queen side it was very difficult
to understand what is going on and
such kind of positions required a lot of
calculations because in
in every move you should understand what
is going on if he'll take only five now
if he'll
maneuver the queen if you play g4 h4
many lines
and we can see that in this game they
both show high quality of plays it's why
i said that they
to i felt like a two terminators place
today yeah
the position was totally dynamic and uh
you need to be aware of all the details
and this is what they did
yes and also refer to the what golfing
said about karana uh
karana showed uh his strengths so far in
this tournament
and we are curious to know what uh what
will happen next um
regarding this uh let us now look at the
pairings for for the next round 11 which
will take place
on friday since tomorrow is the rest day
yes so in the next round
we have uh yanni pomnishi facing caruana
i guess
this one is is the one
yes the the sole leader of the
tournament will be facing
one of uh one of the
the the players
who magnus carlsen himself puts on the
topic
what is your experience dina obviously
you had this situation in your career
when you are leading and you face the
most dangerous opponent
what is your strategy what is your
advice to yan how should he play
i do have to say something about this
one i actually
consider that it will be way more
stressful for yaniponishi
than for carolina because jan is the
leader and he has
something to he has something to lose
while karana has nothing to lose since
he's
he's trying to get the the first place
from his chair if you see what i mean
yes it uh i think it very much depends
uh
of the fears of the players so before
this game they have a very difficult
fire
fight with the fears karana fear can be
that if he lost again the tournament
will be over with his draws he will
still
still have a chances at the other side
if jan loses the game he will still be
the leader so it's
it's okay it will be unpleasant but his
chances still be
would be very high uh what i'm talking
about here is uh doesn't matter what you
decide
or you decide to play extremely sharp or
you decided to play extremely solid
you should just do it without any fears
and just get what you will get
and uh of course the boss experience
player and
uh i expect a really interesting chess
wise game
from this round what would be your bet
for
for this one uh my bet would be a
draw i believe that jan is
very pragmatic and with bad pieces he
can control the situation
and i think it will be hard to caruana
to play all-in in this game
so my i i stick
i stick to drawing this game fair enough
jan is playing with the bright pieces
and that gives him a slight advantage
yes the second game of eleventh round
is kirill alex saying against maha
i believe that uh this rest day will be
very good for kirill
uh and also uh how need uh need time to
understand what is going on uh
right now uh this is uh
um let's say this is a game not
uh not with leaders and they have a time
just to play chess just to enjoy this
moment uh to feel
uh their power i think it is also
important for
for both of them because uh they will
have to
to fight for
for at least not being
on the bottom but it's also the fight of
the characters this is what i mean
uh who is uh having
who has more motivation to continue even
if they know
that uh they will be unlikely in the
in the first positions i think they're
both motivated enough they're strong
players and
we will definitely see the extremely
fight there uh i would say that there is
another chasing trick in this match
alexandre is famous by his
combinational style and van gaal as we
already mentioned one positional player
so
it is will be like a style it will be a
clash of the styles
like a tiger against the snake you know
nice i really like this uh this
comparison okay
game number three for the round 11 is uh
alexander grieschuk versus maxim
vashilagraf
yet another interesting game to follow
since maxine vashilyraf is fighting for
for for the title for for the
for the first place he is still fighting
for it and grishok alexander
shook will will do his best in order to
stop the french
to from yes both players showed a very
sharp
play in the first round so grishok was
seeking for complications
in every game and trying to to make
sacrifices or take something and try to
unbalance the position and bashir just
play the most possible
complicated openings in the chess so
this is
will be very exciting games chess wise
especially
considering that grishook is a big
expert in nadorf and
groomfield defense also so for me it's
very curious
will wash here stick to his strategy to
play the most sharp lines possible and
maybe
he he decided to to play something new
so this will be very interesting moment
in this game
so i guess we'll expect a huge
theoretical debate yes
yes that's true and the game number four
of the eleventh round is anish giri
against dean clearan i think we should
expect
again high quality game niche gear
definitely
uh have a wind uh
in his shape so uh and ding clear now is
also looks like
like he found his best play and we can
expect
high quality game in the in this match i
don't think that will be much risk from
both players but
strategically it will be very
interesting yeah right from my side we
will
for one side we'll have anish guri who
is uh
who has already smelt uh this tasted
this
uh this this victory approaching
and he clearly said that uh you do need
to win in order to
to get the the first place and from the
other side we will have
dean levran who actually doesn't have
anything to lose in this case this is
true he doesn't have any tools anymore
and he's
pretty relaxed as he mentioned on one of
the press conferences
so this will be also a thrilling game
yes uh i think it's very exciting
exciting tournament is going on right
now all players
already showed uh their best in some
moments uh
some uh some others still i believe want
to show his preparation he and his best
part
so that's it for us today next round
will be on friday so tomorrow all uh
players and
also our studio will have a res day and
we will
wait you here as usual at 5 pm gmt
please same time same place yes don't
forget to
subscribe put the likes see you on next
show
see you on friday
[Music]
so
you